[Music]
d is with us dee is in kansas city hi
dee how you doing
hey dave i'm doing great thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
well um it's a little overwhelming um
today i just got a check that um we
inherited um just right under two
million dollars how much and
two million
two million dollars
wow
who who who left you this
well my mom and dad but my my dad worked
really really hard and
lived very
conservatively and
you would have never known it growing up
wow
wow
way very long ago really what did that
how long ago did he pass
um
he passed about a little over a year and
then my mom just passed um
just not much very long ago oh wow wow
right together how long were they
married yeah
oh goodness 60 plus years oh my goodness
well i'm sorry for your loss that leaves
a big hole in your life
yeah but yeah it's just a lot to take in
and we just want to be wise
it's just a lot all at once
you get all kinds of financial people
that try to tell you do this do that and
we just my head's been and to be honest
we've worked hard my husband and i um
hey my husband's retired and he's 62 and
i'm 57 and i work part-time what is your
net worth before you got this check
um we have about let's see
1.4 million okay so you were already
millionaires
yeah but um this just kind of all just
happened my husband retired and i mean
we've just been working towards this day
let me tell you how you got 1.4 million
slow
and steady
yes sir and you did it without all of
these financial sharks that are swimming
around you in circles right now like a
jimmy buffett song
yeah
okay yeah we just plugged it on you know
how you get rid of those sharks you
shoot at them with a gun
and they swim off
i'm being metaphorical okay i'm not
saying don't really shoot somebody okay
you you're in kansas it could happen but
um yeah no the uh uh
run them off unless they're your
financial person that you're already
we're dealing with run them off
okay gotcha yeah they're they're there
for the wrong reasons at the wrong time
they have violated their their lack of
class disqualifies them goodbye
all right all right now then so rule
number one
slow down
okay
going fast is bad
going slow is good
a lot of peace in that in there
yeah your dad moved slow
your dad moved slow
you got to 1.4 slow
and the way you're going to properly
handle 2 million extra
is slow
calm down there's no rush
there's no one in a hurry a tornado is
not coming you're fine
okay number two
don't put money in anything
you don't understand
it's your job
to understand it but guess what you were
already a millionaire so you already
understand how to manage wealth you were
already managing wealth
but maybe you need to bone up on it just
a little bit maybe you need to polish up
on your skills a little
nothing wrong with that okay with the
extra weight of this extra
responsibility
so rule one slow down
two don't put money in anything you
don't understand
three do not work with anyone in any
field anywhere in the financial world at
all for that matter anyone anywhere
probably but certainly in the financial
field unless they have the heart of a
teacher
okay and the sharks that are circling
right now don't have the heart of a
teacher get rid of them
all right 85 percent of the people in
the insurance business in the investment
business and the real estate business
in the estate planning business are
sales people 15 of them are teachers
you're looking for one of the 15 percent
and i made that number up by the way but
i'm pretty close
all right
so you have the heart of a teacher
as your advisor
they are not telling you what to do
and you're expected to do it blindly
because you're going to understand it
before you do it and you're going to
slow down
can you handle one more rule
i sure can't
ask yourself
before you do the investment before you
make the move
is this honoring to my father's memory
okay
and the reason i'm having you do that is
your dad was a hero
i want you managing money like he did
and if you think he's in heaven smiling
because you're smart then that's
probably because you're smart
and if you're if you invest in something
you go my dad is up there shaking his
head going uh uh uh uh uh that one's
stupid
and then you know you're doing the wrong
thing right
that's correct yeah
because your dad was unassuming and
steady and wise
consequently
proverbs says a godly man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
that's your dad
okay
if you do those four things kiddo you're
going to be just fine george what do you
want to add one no i just want you guys
to start dreaming about what this does
for you because what it does it gives
you freedom and it gives you options and
so start dreaming about what you want to
do to make this a blessing i don't want
it to give you anxiety i want it to to
give you that feeling of what could we
do with this money do we want to uh you
know there's three things you can do
give save spend where do we want to give
a portion of this how do we want to
spend some of this and enjoy it and how
do we want to save this or put it
towards other goals maybe you want to
buy investment property or do something
absolutely wild you have the freedom to
do that now
hey dee
you're more able to handle this than you
think you are
you already had 1.4 million
you're not dumb
you know more than half the people that
are purporting to give you advice
trust your instincts you have good
instincts
this is the ramsay show